.
Einsamkeit findet im Versteckten
statt, im Verborgenen.
Wer möchte schon preisgeben,
dass er einsam ist?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich fühle mich nicht einsam,
aber alleine.
Ich hatte eine super Kindheit.
Es begann in der Schule,
als ich merkte, dass ich anders bin.
Seinen eigenen Weg zu gehen,
sich selber treu zu bleiben,
wenn man merkt,
man ist ganz alleine,
kann sich mit niemandem
darüber austauschen -
vielleicht verstehen einen
andere auch gar nicht.
Das kann sehr einsam machen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Einsamkeit löst in mir
auch Hilflosigkeit aus.
Ich fühle mich dann
wie in einem Loch.
Es macht mich traurig,
es bringt mich zum Weinen.
Ich versinke manchmal
auch in Selbstmitleid.
Aber das möchte ich gar nicht.
Es schmerzt einfach,
wenn ich alleine unterwegs bin,
wie eigentlich immer oder meistens.
Ich sehe die Menschen lachen,
ich sehe sie in Gruppen
in einem Café -
und ich habe das nicht,
ich gehe daran vorbei.
Ich glaube, es geht mir besser,
wenn ich draussen in der Natur bin.
Jetzt gehen wir ins Restaurant
einen Kaffee trinken.
Wir haben uns schon
in der Schulzeit kennengelernt.
1958 hat es dann gefunkt,
und seither sind wir zusammen.
Wir sind seit 57 Jahren verheiratet.
Wir haben manche Entwicklung
durchgemacht.
Wir hatten auch Probleme,
die wir gemeinsam lösen mussten.
2010 hat es schleichend angefangen.
Man hat gemerkt:
Mona wird immer vergesslicher.
2012 machten wir
die erste Abklärung.
Sie hatte damals schon
eine leichte bis mittlere Demenz.
Schau, jetzt kommt ein Grosser.
Komm.
Fall nicht hin.
Mona merkte damals auch,
dass etwas nicht stimmte.
Sie konnte fuchsteufelswild werden.
Man musste einfach nachgeben,
Fünfe gerade sein lassen.
Man musste einfach mal
Sie haben ihre eigene Meinung,
und die gilt.
Es gibt nichts anderes.
Sie haben
keine Auswahl mehr im Kopf.
Du bist ja einer.
Die Demenz ist ja auch
ein Abschiedsprozess,
ein Abschied auf Raten.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Willst du mir helfen?
Hier hinten bin ich.
Ich war immer irgendwo in der Ecke
oder ganz hinten.
Meine Eltern
waren immer für mich da.
Aber eben, ich hatte das Gefühl ...
Entschuldigung.
... ich könne
einfach nicht darüber reden.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich müsse stark sein.
Deshalb auch diese Heulausbrüche,
denn langsam, aber sicher
kann ich darüber sprechen.
Es war irgendwie schon so:
Ich kam in die Schule,
und vorher war alles gut -
und in der Schule
ging es mir plötzlich schlecht.
Zu Hause möchte man dann
auch nicht darüber sprechen.
Ich hatte nie eine beste Freundin.
Ich wurde immer ausgeschlossen
wegen meines Gewichts,
v.a. auch im Turnunterricht.
Ich wurde immer
als Letzte gewählt.
Ich fühlte mich alleine
und ausgeschlossen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass mir niemand helfe.
Inzwischen stört es mich weniger,
dass ich diese Ausbrüche habe
und weine.
Anfangs
hatte ich wirklich Mühe damit,
ich habe mich geschämt
und versteckt.
Yoda, komm.
Yoda.
Meine Katzen nehmen mich,
wie ich bin,
denen ist es egal, wie ich aussehe.
Bei Yoda ist speziell,
dass er einen Kleinhirnfehler hat.
Er wurde dadurch
auch ein wenig ausgeschlossen.
Ihn konnte man damals im Tierheim
schlecht vermitteln.
Saphira hätte sofort jemand
genommen, aber ihn wollte niemand.
Wir haben später erfahren,
dass er eingeschläfert
hätte werden sollen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Meine persönliche Einsamkeit
besteht aus dem Gefühl,
nicht gesehen zu werden,
abgeschnitten zu sein.
Ich verspüre
eine sehr starke Melancholie.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht dazugehöre.
Ich fühle mich einsam
in Beziehungen mit anderen Menschen.
Bei grösseren Anlässen,
Hochzeiten z.B.
Oder ich höre auf einem Konzert
ein bestimmtes Lied
und fühle mich in diesem Moment
nicht mit meinen Freunden verbunden.
Ich weiss aber, dass das wenig
mit den Freunden zu tun hat,
sondern mit meinem anscheinend
sehr stark ausgeprägten Bedürfnis
nach einer bestimmten Art
von sozialer oder emotionaler Nähe.
Es kann sehr plötzlich kommen,
ich weiss aber,
dass es auch wieder verschwindet.
Dieses Gefühl von Einsamkeit gehört
sehr stark zu meiner Geschichte.
Meine Einsamkeit kommt auch daher,
dass meine Möglichkeiten
aufgrund meines Einkommens
eingeschränkt sind.
Ich hatte bis vor rund einem Jahr
einen Nischenarbeitsplatz
und stand im Erwerbsleben.
Da hatte ich auch noch
mehr Geld zur Verfügung.
Ich ging auch noch öfters
mal am Abend ein Bier trinken.
Aber seither
bin ich schon mehr zu Hause.
Ich lebe von einer IV-Rente.
Ich komme durchs Leben,
muss mich aber einschränken.
Am besten geht es mir,
wenn ich spazieren
oder wandern gehe.
Ich habe schon seit 16 Jahren
kein eigenes Auto mehr
und vermisse es auch nicht.
Den Takt bewusst wahrnehmen,
das Wiederkehrende,
das tut mir sehr gut.
Das gibt mir
eine Art eigene Sicherheit,
meinen eigenen Schritt zu erleben,
das Vibrieren, das Aufschlagen,
im Takt zu bleiben.
Ich rieche gerne
den Duft des Waldes,
ich höre gerne das Rauschen
des Windes, der Wellen.
Ich spaziere
auch sehr gerne am Bodensee.
Die offene Landschaft, die Weite -
darum fühle ich mich wohl dort.
* Leichte Musik *
Mona ist im Heim.
Ich besuche sie,
aber ich muss alles alleine machen.
Ich male in letzter Zeit -
Erinnerungen von schönen Reisen.
Das gibt mir ein Gefühl
von Verbundenheit mit Mona.
Wir hatten doch eine so schöne Zeit.
Wenn wir hier sassen,
hat Mona beim Pilatus drüben
immer etwas gesehen, z.B. Wolken.
Sie hat immer etwas gefragt
und etwas gesehen.
Das machte sie dann halt
manchmal 30- bis 40-mal am Tag,
aber ich gab immer Antwort.
Und dann hatte ich
einen totalen Zusammenbruch.
Physisch, psychisch, Herzprobleme.
Ich konnte noch meine Tochter
und die Notfallnummer anrufen
und Mona weismachen,
dass sie die Tür öffnen soll,
wenn die Sanität kommt.
An diesem Punkt sagte der Körper:
"Es geht nicht mehr."
Und dann sagte meine Tochter:
"Hör zu, Papi, Mona kann
nicht mehr bei dir bleiben,
es ist zu viel für dich."
"Wir müssen sie
in einem Heim platzieren."
Nachdem wir
einen Platz gefunden hatten
und aus dem Auto
gestiegen waren, meinte Mona:
"Das ist ja das Heim. Hier will ich
nicht bleiben, bis ich sterbe."
Das hat wehgetan.
Wir mussten uns verabschieden.
Die Abschiede waren grauenhaft.
Aber beim Ausgang
hatte es eine Kiste mit Äpfeln.
Daraus habe ich immer
einen Apfel genommen,
ihn auf dem Heimweg gegessen -
damit konnte ich das Ganze
ein wenig verdauen.
Bei der Lehrstellensuche
hiess es oft:
"Du schaffst das sowieso nicht."
"Mit deinem Übergewicht
können wir dich nicht einstellen."
Oft bekam ich
nicht mal eine Antwort.
Ich lernte nachher Hauswart,
also Fachfrau Betriebsunterhalt.
Ich suchte einen entsprechenden Job,
fand aber nichts.
Schliesslich wurde ich
als Zimmermädchen eingestellt -
in dem Restaurant,
in dem ich heute arbeite.
Ich musste manchmal
in der Küche aushelfen, abwaschen,
mal einen Kuchen backen -
so hat sich das alles ergeben.
* Telefonklingeln *
Zweimal Schnipo neu,
zweimal nicht zu gross.
Wird das fertig bis Abend?
Sie wirbelt hier herum
wie eine Wahnsinnige.
Treppe rauf, Treppe runter,
sie macht und tut -
mehr als manch ein anderer.
Sie macht das super.
Ich bin froh, dass Debby da ist.
Sie hat auch einen gewissen Schalk.
Ich glaube, sie ist sehr gerne hier.
Wir mögen sie sehr.
Es ist das erste Mal, dass ich mich
in einem Team wirklich wohl
und angenommen fühle -
so wie ich bin.
Ich fühlte mich
schon als Kind einsam.
Ich hatte einen strengen Vater.
Die Stimmung daheim
empfand ich als von Macht geprägt.
Ich musste immer brav
und folgsam sein.
Und bloss nicht widersprechen.
Ich hatte Angst, zu versagen,
wenn ich nicht perfekt bin.
Das habe ich gelernt: perfekt sein.
Meine Mutter konnte sich
auch nicht durchsetzen.
Deshalb konnte ich mich
auch nicht an sie wenden.
Dadurch fühlte ich mich isoliert.
Ich hatte Angst,
in die Schule zu gehen.
Das machte mich
dann auch zum Einzelgänger.
Es macht mich sehr traurig,
was ich da aushalten musste.
Ich erlebte auch schöne Zeiten
mit meinen Eltern, sicherlich.
Materiell ging es mir sehr gut,
ich hatte alles.
Ich hatte Angst,
das Leben alleine zu meistern.
Aus heutiger Sicht bereue ich,
dass ich nicht früher
ausgezogen bin.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Meine Freiheit begann erst mit 20,
als ich mein erstes Auto kaufte.
Das war eine Art Befreiungsschlag
aus dieser Strenge,
die ich in der Kindheit
erlebt hatte.
Ein für mich
einschneidendes Erlebnis
war eine sehr schwere Krankheit,
als ich 14 war.
Ich hatte einen Gehirntumor.
Relativ lange Zeit war nicht klar,
ob ich diesen Tumor überleben werde.
Mit mir hat damals
keiner darüber geredet, nein.
Am schlimmsten war, dass alle meine
Freunde mich nicht besuchen durften.
Ihnen wurde gesagt,
ich werde sterben,
und meine Freunde sollten mich
halt nicht im Sterbeprozess sehen.
Da habe ich mich
sehr, sehr einsam gefühlt.
Und zwar sah ich
ein schwarzes, grosses Loch,
also eine Art Abgrund,
in den ich falle,
weil mich keiner hält.
Als Kind merkte ich,
dass ich eine Belastung
für andere Menschen bin,
dass es meinen Eltern und
meinem Bruder sehr schlecht geht,
weil ich so krank bin.
Ich wollte die Sache beenden,
damit es allen wieder gut geht.
Ich hatte vor, alleine auf Toilette
zu gehen und Tabletten zu nehmen.
Ich entschied mich dann aber,
die Tabletten nicht zu nehmen
und sie runterzuspülen.
* Sanfte, schwebende Klänge *
Ich glaube, das gab mir bis heute
viel Lebensenergie und Kraft.
Ich denke, es hat sehr viel mit
diesem Moment im Krankenhaus zu tun,
als ich mich entschied,
mich nicht umzubringen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wenn ich weg war
und dann die Wohnung betrete:
diese Stille.
Leer, kein Leben, kein Ton.
Dann sitze ich oft auf dem Stuhl,
auf dem Mona immer sass.
Sie schaute hier zum Fenster raus
in Richtung Pilatus.
Ich wollte das verarbeiten,
das ausdrücken können.
Und dann habe ich ...
diese Karte gemalt.
Der Stuhl mit dem
verschwommenen Pilatus, diese Leere.
Ich schickte die Karte
meinen Bekannten, Verwandten,
Freunden und Freundinnen.
Darüber reden, raustragen,
nicht verstecken.
So bekommt man auch
Hilfe und Verständnis.
Ich habe das dann weitergeführt.
Ich dachte
an die vier Jahreszeiten.
Und so entstand
die Weihnachtskarte für Dezember.
Hier war der Stuhl
nur noch sehr klein.
Ich denke oft an Mona.
Auch am Abend, wenn ich lese,
im Wohnzimmer sitze und lese
und manchmal müde werde
und fast einschlafe,
habe ich manchmal das Gefühl,
plötzlich so im Halbschlaf,
es sitze jemand neben mir -
und wenn ich aufwache,
verschwindet dieses Gefühl.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
Mona sei hier gewesen.
Mein Vater war am Anfang
nicht so glücklich
mit der Auswahl meines Freundes.
Und weil mein Vater
seit Jahren Bass gespielt hat,
hat auch Stephan angefangen,
Bass zu spielen,
damit sie ein Gesprächsthema hatten.
Stephan hatte viel Spass dabei,
lernte das Instrument
in kurzer Zeit zu spielen
und hat jetzt eine eigene Band.
Er arbeitet auch in der Gastronomie.
Ich habe Sonntag und Montag frei
und er Dienstag und Mittwoch.
Wenn wir mal Zeit
zusammen haben,
spielen wir gerne Spiele
oder machen Ausflüge.
Deborah ist mein Ausgleich.
Wenn mir alles zu viel wird,
ist sie der Pol,
der mich wieder
in die Normalität bringt.
He! Hör auf, mich zu schlagen!
Mit Deborahs Gewicht
hatte ich nie ein Problem.
Ich habe allgemein kein Problem mit
Menschen, die irgendwie anders sind.
Ihre Einsamkeit
verstehe ich sehr gut.
Ich hatte das früher auch.
Mit der Musik
habe ich einen Ausgleich.
Ich habe Leute,
die ich regelmässig treffe.
So habe ich das überwunden.
Bis Corona war ich eigentlich
mehr unterwegs als zu Hause.
Ich arbeite
als selbstständige Beraterin
im Bereich der Friedensförderung
der internationalen Zusammenarbeit,
z.B. in Syrien oder im Libanon.
Ich beschäftige mich
sehr viel mit der Frage,
wie man sicherstellen kann,
dass man die Menschen,
mit denen man
in Kriegskontexten zusammenarbeitet,
nicht unbeabsichtigt traumatisiert.
Diese Sensibilität für Menschen,
die ausgeschlossen sind,
ist auch ein Geschenk,
weil ich so
auf Menschen zugehen kann.
Ich kann mich
in sie hineinversetzen,
indem ich versuche, verschiedene
Perspektiven zu berücksichtigen,
und eben sicherstelle, dass sich
niemand ausgeschlossen fühlt.
Als Selbstständige
kommt mir sehr zugute,
dass ich sehr gerne alleine arbeite.
Und wenn ich Lust
auf einen Kaffee habe,
dann gehe ich eben in ein Café,
lese Zeitung,
und das geniesse ich dann auch sehr.
Alleinsein ist eine wichtige
Prophylaxe gegen Einsamkeit.
Wenn ich lerne,
bewusst alleine zu sein,
fühle ich mich auch weniger einsam.
Ich hatte immer Angst,
ich müsse alles geben,
damit ich die Erwartungen
des Arbeitgebers erfülle.
Anfangs
war die Arbeitsplatzsituation
noch nicht so mit Druck behaftet.
Aber in den letzten Jahrzehnten
hat das stetig zugenommen.
Ich konnte der Situation
einfach nicht mehr gerecht werden.
Es hat mich alles überfordert.
2012 bin ich
in eine tiefe Depression gestürzt.
Meine Frau und ich
waren neun Jahre verheiratet.
Zwei Jahre zuvor war die Trennung,
und ich musste
aus der Familienwohnung ausziehen.
Ich war dem wiederum
hilflos ausgesetzt.
Ich musste es einfach hinnehmen.
Und ja, das hat mich einfach
aus der Bahn geworfen.
Ich musste zuerst einmal
alleine damit fertig werden,
mit all diesen Situationen.
Mit wem hätte ich denn
darüber reden sollen?
* Sanfte,
melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Erst vor gut einem Jahr
hatte ich genügend Kraft,
um auszumisten.
Es tut mir auch nicht gut,
der Vergangenheit nachzutrauern.
Ich will eben
auch wieder vorwärtsschauen.
* Leichte Musik *
Ich räume zu Hause auf, das sind
alles noch Sachen meiner Kinder.
Alles Spielzeug,
sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, Spielzeug
oder Experimentierkästen.
Aber mein Sohn
spielt schon lange nicht mehr damit.
Sieht gut aus.
- Ich brauche etwas Veränderung.
Die Spiele sind ja fast wie neu.
Ja, sie sind gut erhalten -
aber ob sie funktionieren?
Brauchst du die Taschen wieder?
- Ja, gerne.
Besten Dank. Merci.
- Danke. Corona-Gruss.
Hier wäre der Eingang.
Danke, Daniel.
Viel Vergnügen.
Vielen Dank.
* Vereinzelte Gitarrenakkorde *
Mona wurde durch ihre Krankheit
sehr anhänglich.
Abends hielt sie im Bett meine Hand,
bis sie eingeschlafen war.
Als sie am Morgen aufwachte, griff
sie mit ihrer Hand zuerst zu mir,
um zu schauen, ob ich da sei.
Dass sie trotz ihrer Demenz
so an mir hing,
war auch immer
etwas ganz Wunderbares.
Dieser Tagesstart: Wenn ich sie
für das Frühstück geholt habe,
habe ich sie umarmt.
Das ist das, was mir fehlt,
jetzt, da ich alleine bin.
Auch wenn es ...
... nicht direkt ein Dialog war,
so war doch noch jemand da -
ein Mensch, den man lieb hatte,
den man umarmen und spüren konnte.
Ich finde, richtig zu essen,
ist etwas,
das man im Alter beachten sollte.
Die Ernährung
sollte ausgewogen sein.
Das kommt vielleicht vom Beruf als
Grafiker und von der Ästhetik her,
dass ich
auch für mich schön anrichte.
Das hilft natürlich auch
über manches hinweg.
Ich bin nun mal so,
ich bin ein wenig ein Geniesser.
Auch für mich allein
kann ich es noch geniessen.
Manchmal dünkt es mich schon,
es wäre noch schön,
wenn Mona neben mir wäre.
Auch wenn es mühsam wäre, würde es
dennoch etwas die Stille brechen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es so ist
oder ob ich es mir einbilde,
aber ich werde oft angeschaut.
Manchmal sieht man Leute tuscheln
und man schämt sich halt.
Ich habe z.B. Mühe,
in der Öffentlichkeit zu essen.
Beim Einkaufen habe ich das Gefühl,
dass die Leute schauen,
was die da jetzt kauft.
Man sagte mir auch schon:
"Du dicke Sau, mach mal Sport."
Aber eben -
in ein Fitnesscenter oder so ...
Rundum die trainierten Leute, die
denken: "Was will jetzt die hier?"
Inzwischen kann ich es ignorieren,
aber es schmerzt trotzdem.
* Melancholische Musik *
Eines meiner Lieblingslieder
von Stephans Band Rimfire
ist das Lied "Ghost".
# I'd like to be a ghost,
to disappear.
Ich möchte ein Gespenst sein
und verschwinden.
Man fühlt sich nicht akzeptiert
und allein
und man möchte etwas anderes sein.
* Vogelgezwitscher *
* Elektronische Klänge *
Ich schwimme sehr gerne,
weil man sich
einfach leichter fühlt, schwerelos.
Es ist nichts,
das einen runterzieht oder ...
Es ist einfach ein schönes Gefühl.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Ich hatte lange Mühe, mich irgendwo
in einer Badi oder so zu zeigen.
Aber inzwischen denke ich:
"Dann sollen die doch schauen."
Nach jahrelangen Versuchen, immer
abzunehmen und sich anzupassen,
hat man irgendwann einfach genug.
Wir wissen, 30-40 % der Bevölkerung
fühlen sich oft bis sehr oft einsam.
Das sind erschreckend hohe Zahlen.
Die sagen einiges über
gesellschaftliche Entwicklungen aus.
Wie wir mit Anderssein umgehen,
wie wir überhaupt Solidarität leben.
Und das macht mir
sehr grosse Sorgen.
Es gibt eigentlich drei Gründe,
warum ich dieses Buch
angefangen habe zu schreiben.
Vor sechs Jahren
ist meine Mutter sehr früh gestorben
und ich habe mich von meinem
schwer depressiven Mann getrennt
oder trennen müssen.
Damit war für mich auch klar,
dass ich keine Kinder haben werde.
Wenn man
einen sehr starken Kinderwunsch hat
und das dann nicht sein soll,
ist das halt einfach
vor allen Dingen sehr schmerzhaft.
Ich glaube, die drei Ereignisse ha-
ben mich sehr einsam fühlen lassen.
Das Thema ist so vielschichtig,
enthält viele Facetten.
Es hat sehr viel
mit mir selber zu tun,
hat aber auch verschiedene politi-
sche und philosophische Dimensionen,
dass ich dachte, dort irgendwie
dranbleiben zu müssen.
Über Einsamkeit zu reden
sollte kein Tabuthema sein,
was es ja sehr oft leider noch ist.
Ich glaube,
das hat sehr viel damit zu tun,
dass wir nicht gelernt haben,
über Verletzbarkeit zu reden.
Ich empfinde vor allen Dingen
auch eine grosse Dankbarkeit,
dass das Buch ganz unterschiedliche
Prozesse ausgelöst hat.
Dass ich Veranstaltungen plane
mit Organisationen zum Thema
Einsamkeit während Corona,
dass verschiedene Institutionen
Interesse haben,
dieses Thema in
Weiterbildungsangebote aufzunehmen.
Ich sah das Bild und wusste:
"Das ist genau mein Verständnis
von Einsamkeit."
Einsamkeit ist auch immer
der Spiegel von
gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen.
Deswegen dachte ich: "Das muss
das Bild für mein Buch sein."
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich fühle mich wohl im Sunnehüsli.
Ich bin regelmässig dort.
Hoi, Daniel.
- Hoi, Meggy.
Bist du auch wieder mal da?
Der Umgangston
ist so natürlich schön.
So familiär, es ist wie Heimat.
Ich esse dort immer
etwa das Gleiche,
weil mir dieser Ablauf guttut.
Es ist alles berechenbar,
und ich brauche das.
Es ist wie eine Sicherheit,
die ich dort habe.
Ich verzichte lieber
auf etwas anderes im Alltag,
aber für das Sunnehüsli
muss immer Geld vorhanden sein.
Wir haben noch zwei Frauen,
die jodeln.
Aha, okay.
Allein der Duft des Apfelkuchens
weckt Erinnerungen an die
vergangenen Zeiten im Sunnehüsli,
als ich noch mit meinen drei Kindern
immer wieder dort war.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Sanfte Musik, Plätschern *
In der Familie fühlte ich mich
geborgen, ich hatte eine Aufgabe.
Ich gab auch meinen ganzen Einsatz
als Familienvater.
Ich merke halt bei den Kindern,
dass sie schon auch
ihr eigenes Leben haben.
Das ist ganz normal.
Sie werden erwachsen
und dann ist halt der Vater
nicht mehr an erster Stelle.
Aber ich kann recht gut
damit umgehen,
weil ich die Kinder
immerhin von Zeit zu Zeit sehe.
Schau mal, Stephan. Es ist spekta-
kulär, was man da so alles sieht.
Schau mal dort,
hast du gesehen beim Schiff dort?
Wenn ich meine Kinder besuche,
gehe ich mit grossen Erwartungen,
und wenn ich wieder zurückfahre,
muss ich mich wieder mit den Ein-
drücken beschäftigen, die ich hatte,
und muss das wieder
allein verarbeiten.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Türklingel *
Ich habe mich bei Zeitgut gemeldet.
Dort habe ich Frau Triponez
kennengelernt.
Grüezi, Frau Triponez.
- Grüezi, Herr Reichlin.
Bitte, herzlich willkommen.
Soll ich die Schuhe ausziehen?
- Nein.
Wir sind eine Genossenschaft,
Zeitgut Luzern.
Wir leisten Nachbarschaftshilfe
mit Zeitgutschriften.
Wir haben rund
520 Genossenschafterinnen
und Genossenschafter.
Mit einer Mitgliedschaft
ist man in ein soziales Netzwerk
eingebunden.
Jeder bestimmt selbst,
wie viel er da machen will.
Herr Reichlin, vielen Dank,
dass ich hierkommen durfte,
um noch mehr von Ihnen zu hören.
Ich mache allerlei. Ich bin interes-
siert an Ausstellungen und Kunst.
Okay.
Und ich habe ein grosses Hobby:
Kochen.
Ich helfe auch jemandem beim Kochen,
wenn er damit nicht zurechtkommt.
Schön.
Meine Frau Mona
ist seit gut zwei Jahren im Heim.
Ich kann mit ihr
nicht mehr gut kommunizieren,
das geht nicht mehr.
Darum bin ich sehr froh
um Kommunikation, Kontakt
und Gespräche.
Das schätze ich also sehr.
- Ja.
Was kochen Sie denn gerne?
Ja, das ist ...
Das kann etwas Einfaches
bis zu einem Sechsgänger sein.
Okay.
Einfach, also ...
Einen Braten oder Hacktätschli
selbst machen ...
Oder auch Wild,
mal ein schönes Wildbuffet machen.
Also eine richtige Leidenschaft ...
Ich hatte schon davon gehört.
Dann bin ich Zeitgut beigetreten.
Jetzt, da ich allein bin,
bin ich froh um solche Begegnungen.
Das ist etwas, das mich reizt,
und ich hoffe,
dass es zustande kommt.
* Ruhige Musik, Motorengeräusch *
(Cordula) Wann ich
meine Einsamkeit thematisiere,
hängt stark von den Menschen ab,
mit denen ich zusammen bin.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass mir Reden generell hilft.
Es hilft mir nur
mit den richtigen Leuten.
Wenn ich den Eindruck habe,
die können das aushalten,
die nehmen das nicht persönlich,
dann traue ich mich,
das auch zu thematisieren.
Nati ist eine Freundin, die
sehr gut versteht, wie es mir geht.
Wir haben sehr viel gemeinsam
erlebt, haben ähnliche Interessen.
Ich bin einfach
gern mit ihr zusammen.
Wie haben die Leute
auf dein Buch reagiert?
Du hast schon
ein paar verkauft, oder?
Ja, ich schaue nicht jeden Tag,
wie viel, aber ...
Ich würde.
- Was?
- Nein.
Bist du nicht neugierig?
- Doch.
Aber ich kann es nicht ändern.
Zeig es mal,
ich habe es noch nicht gesehen.
Ich finde es ein schönes Layout.
Wenn ich Leuten erzähle, dass du
ein Buch über Einsamkeit schreibst,
fragen sie gleich: "Sie ist einsam?"
- Ja, genau.
Wenn ich sage, ich sei auch manchmal
einsam, fragen sie dasselbe.
Die Leute
haben ein schlechtes Gewissen,
weil sie nicht genügend oft anrufen.
Ich versuche zu erklären,
dass das nichts mit dir zu tun hat.
Ich glaube schon,
dass viele das Gefühl haben,
als Freunde nicht zu genügen,
weil ich mich einsam fühle.
Ja, das habe ich auch so oft gehört.
- Mhm.
Wahrscheinlich können wir deshalb
so gut darüber reden -
warum wir uns einsam fühlen.
Die andere hat nicht das Gefühl,
eine schlechte Freundin zu sein.
Wenn jemand mich nicht versteht,
dann ...
Bei mir entsteht dann
schnell das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht so akzeptiert werde,
wie ich bin,
und eigentlich auch nicht dafür
geschätzt oder geliebt werde.
Es hat alle Leute erstaunt, als ich
dieses Buch herausgegeben habe.
Wenn man mich nicht gut kennt,
kann ich verstehen,
dass es irritiert, dass ich
ein Thema habe mit Einsamkeit.
* Türklingel *
Üblicherweise
kommt Frau Weber jede Woche,
und das gibt mir auch
eine Sicherheit,
weil ich weiss,
dass ich sie dann wiedersehe.
Das hatte ich in der Psychotherapie
im ähnlichen Stil auch,
aber dort war es einfach
distanzierter.
Das kenne ich im Umgang
mit Frau Weber nicht.
Wie ist es Ihnen seit unserem
letzten Termin ergangen?
Psychiatrische Spitex differenziert
sich von der normalen Spitex darin,
dass wir keine Körperpflege
anbieten, keine Verbände.
Unser Auftrag ist,
Menschen mit psychologischen
oder eben auch
psychiatrischen Einschränkungen
im Alltag zu begleiten.
Wir arbeiten
mit dem Bezugspersonensystem.
Es kommt nicht jede Woche
jemand anderes zum Klienten.
Der Aufbau eines
Vertrauensverhältnisses
und eine Verbindlichkeit
sind gewährleistet.
Auch allein zu essen zu Hause ...
... ist halt irgendwo ein Problem.
Die Motivation
ist nicht so vorhanden.
Wir hatten auch das Thema,
dass es in St. Gallen
auch niederschwellige
Mittagstischsituationen gäbe.
Vielleicht ist es
für das Budget ungünstig,
dreimal in der Woche zu gehen, aber
dass man einmal dort essen geht.
Vielleicht könnte man auch
andere Menschen ausfindig machen,
um gemeinsam zu kochen.
Denken Sie, es gäbe so etwas?
Ich weiss beim besten Willen
nichts über ein solches Angebot,
gemeinsam zu kochen.
- Mhm.
Aber ich finde es
eine bestechende Idee.
Gemeinsam etwas zu erreichen,
das würde mir gefallen.
Einfach zu wissen,
dass es so etwas geben würde ...
Laden Sie doch mal jemanden ein,
den Sie kennen.
Ja ...
Sie macht mir Mut
für eine Veränderung.
Sie würde mir sogar helfen,
etwas aufzuräumen.
Von diesem Angebot
machte ich noch keinen Gebrauch.
Ich bin stolz,
wenn ich es allein schaffe.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Für mich ist der Unterschied
zwischen einsam fühlen
und allein sein ...
Einsam sein möchte man eigentlich
nicht, das tut auch weh.
Allein sein
kann manchmal auch schön sein,
wenn man einfach mal Ruhe braucht
und sich zurückziehen kann.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wenn ich alleine unterwegs bin,
gefällt mir einfach die Ruhe
und dass ich mich
auf etwas konzentrieren kann.
Ich fotografiere sehr gern.
V.a. Landschaftsbilder,
aber auch Tiere.
Ich bin glücklich und fühle mich
wohl, wenn ich in der Natur bin.
Wenn ich einfach sein kann,
wie ich bin.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin
sehr katholisch aufgewachsen.
Für jeden sieht Gott
ja irgendwie anders aus.
Für mich sind es die Verbundenheit
und die Ruhe in der Natur.
Ich merke, dass jemand da ist,
der zu mir schaut.
Es tut sicher gut,
wenn man Gedanken so loswerden kann.
Ich fresse nicht mehr alles
in mich rein wie früher,
sondern ich denke darüber nach
oder spreche auch
mit anderen Leuten darüber.
Loslassen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenakkorde *
* Summton *
Ich habe schon oft
in fremden Küchen gekocht.
Ich weiss schnell, wo das Zeug ist,
das ist kein Problem.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Wenn ich allein esse,
esse ich viel zu schnell.
Ich koche auch nicht gern -
für mich allein.
Dann lasse ich das Essen
halt liefern.
Ich esse dann trotzdem allein,
ich bin ja allein.
Ich bin froh, dass Walti da ist
und für mich kocht.
Dann können wir miteinander essen
und auch diskutieren.
Es ist wie in einem Restaurant,
sogar noch besser,
weil es mit viel Liebe gemacht
wurde. Und das merkt man.
Wir haben uns schon
vom Sehen her gekannt.
Meine Frau hat Chantal
von der Seniorenbühne gekannt
oder auch sonst aus dem Quartier.
Sie ist auch schon lange hier.
Frau Triponez
hat eine tolle Wahl getroffen.
Wir haben wirklich
eine schöne Tischgemeinschaft.
(Leise) Danke schön.
- Bitte.
Vielen Dank.
Pf...
Es schmeckt wahnsinnig lecker.
Von wem wird Mona jetzt betreut?
Sie ist in der Demenzabteilung und
da sind immer vier, fünf Leute da.
Aber immer die gleichen?
Ja, immer die gleichen.
Das ganze Team
umfasst etwa 20 Leute,
aber natürlich im Schichtbetrieb.
Frühschicht, Nachmittagschicht,
Spätschicht, Nachtwache.
So ist das aufgeteilt.
Jetzt gibt es dann
noch Lammrücken ...
Fein.
... Ofenkartoffeln
und Ofenkürbis ...
Ja?
... Brokkoli und Rüebli.
Ein wenig ausgarniert.
Stille macht mich auch einsam.
Schlimm ist es halt v.a.
gegen Abend.
Dann bin ich einfach allein.
Vor etwa einem Jahr habe ich mich
bei Sozialkontakt.ch angemeldet.
Um möglicherweise
jemanden kennenzulernen
oder mich einer Freizeitgruppe
anzuschliessen.
Ja, ich habe meine Hoffnung,
dass ich da vielleicht mal meine
Wanderpartnerin kennenlerne ...
... und vielleicht einfach
meine zukünftige Freundin.
In einer neuen Paarbeziehung wünsche
ich mir tiefe Verbundenheit, Liebe.
Also Liebe schenken, Liebe nehmen.
Füreinander da sein,
akzeptiert zu werden, wie man ist.
Das wünscht sich doch jeder Mensch,
so angenommen zu werden, wie er ist.
Ich möchte mich
nicht verstellen müssen.
Nicht mehr.
Ob man für jeden Neuanfang
kämpfen muss, weiss ich nicht.
Ich denke, es darf im Leben
auch mal leichter gehen,
aber ich muss das noch lernen.
Ich habe das nicht
in die Wiege gelegt bekommen,
dass Leben auch einfach geht.
Das ist ein Teil meiner Biografie,
dass ich immer wieder
sehr schwere Momente im Leben hatte,
aber die waren sehr oft
auch ein spannender Neuanfang.
"Bird Of Sorrow" von meinem
Lieblingssänger Glen Hansard
löst eine tiefe Melancholie aus.
Das habe ich sehr oft gehört,
als ich mich von meinem damaligen
Mann getrennt habe.
(Englisch)
Es ist für mich ein Lied voller
Trauer, auch voller Verzweiflung,
aber es hat auch sehr viel Kraft
für mich.
Es geht eben auch darum,
dass jeder Schmerz
im Leben Platz haben darf
und man nie aufgeben soll.
Und dass
auch etwas Neues entstehen kann.
Eine neue Liebe, eine neue
Begegnung, eine neue Energie.
Ich habe mich in vielen
Liebesbeziehungen einsam gefühlt.
Ich habe mich nicht getraut,
das zu artikulieren.
Ich habe das einfach akzeptiert
als einen Teil von mir.
In der jetzigen Beziehung
habe ich das grosse Glück,
dass ich einen Mann an meiner Seite
habe, dem ich das sagen kann,
der damit auch umgehen und
meine Einsamkeit verstehen kann.
Das Gefühl, dass ich
so geliebt werde, wie ich bin,
ist für mich
ein wahnsinniges Geschenk.
Damit hätte ich nicht mehr
gerechnet, ehrlich gesagt.
Und ja das ist - wow -
einmalig für mich.
Heute ist es für mich
nicht mehr so schlimm.
Ich habe mich damit abgefunden,
wie ich bin.
Zwischendurch packt mich
wieder die Lust auf Veränderungen
und dann muss
etwas komplett anderes her.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass die Menschen nicht nur
nach dem Aussehen urteilen.
Man sollte einfach etwas offener
aufeinander zugehen.
Zieh mal schnell die Maske runter.
Ich finde es cool.
- Total anders, oder?
Gut!
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Man meint,
man könne alles selber bewältigen.
Aber es kommt ein Zeitpunkt,
wo man über den eigenen Schatten
springen muss.
So oft hört man, dass sich
die Leute zurückziehen,
sich verstecken
und nicht darüber reden wollen.
Um da rauszukommen, gibt es nichts
anderes als professionelle Hilfe.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
ich sei alleine mit dieser
Einsamkeit, ich sei der Einzige.
Über Einsamkeit sollte man
eigentlich viel mehr reden.
Ich bin überzeugt, man würde
so viele verbündete Menschen finden.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Ph. Schlatter, A. Werlen - 2021